Traduttore: Sara Tecco
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
Non è vero che a me
preoccupa la comunicazione, anzi:
la osservo, mi piace.
Cosa sto pensando, in questo momento?
Che le mie due dimensioni,
spazio e tempo -- hanno dei limiti.
La dimensione temporale
è limitata dal countdown
che mi sta segnando il tempo
che ho a disposizione.
La disposizione, invece,
di questo cerchio ai miei piedi
è il limite della mia dimensione spaziale.
Non posso travalicare il limite
di questo cerchio rosso,
perché uscirei dal fuoco delle telecamere
e quindi perderei un'occasione unica
di lasciare un momento epico
della mia esistenza
che sicuramente mi sopravviverà.
Quindi, in questi 15 minuti,
io sto lasciando qualcosa all'umanità,
sto realizzando la mia etica individuale,
in un luogo privilegiato,
senz'altro, senza dubbio,
per una storia personale,
per una professione,
per una serie di botte
di fortuna o di infamità:
ho iniziato a fare il giornalista
con una finta raccomandazione
di uno zio arcivescovo
che non ho mai avuto
ma era l'unica maniera che si aveva
per poter cercare di ambire
a varcare i confini dell'azienda pubblica,
dove c'era quel cavallo morente.
Detto questo, vorrei sfatare innanzitutto
quello che è un luogo comune:
che viviamo nell'epoca
della comunicazione.
No, non è affatto vero:
non è la cifra fondamentale
dell'epoca in cui viviamo,
quella che noi comunichiamo.
Noi non stiamo comunicando:
in realtà, ci stiamo
semplicemente addestrando
a quella che è una fase inconsapevole
della nostra evoluzione.
Cerco di essere più chiaro.
Noi - più o meno,
i miei dati sono del tutto imprecisi,
ma faccio il giornalista
perché amo l'imprecisione,
sennò farei lo scienziato -
abbiamo più o meno cominciato
a camminare eretti 20 milioni di anni fa.
Poi abbiamo impiegato
altri 15-17 milioni di anni
per diventare uomini a tutti gli effetti.
E qual è stato il segno
della nostra evoluzione?
Perché noi siamo stati
una specie privilegiata,
perché siamo qui noi
a parlare dentro un anfiteatro,
e abbiamo pensieri complessi?
Per un banalissimo episodio:
che ci è spuntato il pollice opponibile.
L'inizio della nostra evoluzione
è questo pollice,
che io possa fare così,
possa schioccare le dita,
possa avvitare un bullone,
possa trasformare la mia mano
in un utensile
e quindi cambiare il mondo attorno a me.
Una semplice evoluzione,
il pollice opponibile,
ci rende quello che siamo.
Abbiamo cominciato quindi
a trasformare il mondo,
avendo il pollice opponibile
cambiavamo il mondo,
siamo diventati veramente
gli architetti dell'universo,
come dicono i massoni,
ma lo siamo a tutti gli effetti
perché non ci siamo accontentati
di cambiare il mondo fisico,
abbiamo cominciato anche a costruirci
un fantastico mondo
metafisico, bellissimo,
e anche in questo
noi siamo stati molto bravi:
abbiamo sempre immaginato
come abbiamo cominciato
a costruire delle macchine -
abbiamo cominciato a costruire
delle macchine che cambiassero il mondo:
la ruota, la leva,
e poi, andando avanti
fino ad arrivare, che ne so,
alla vite senza fine, al cardano.
[Con] tutti gli attrezzi
che ci siamo inventati,
che via via hanno costruito la tecnologia,
abbiamo cambiato il nostro mondo.
Non abbiamo cambiato
soltanto il nostro mondo
ma anche quello delle idee.
Abbiamo cominciato a costruirci
delle fantastiche architetture
per dare possibilità
di visualizzare o di appoggiare
quelli che erano i nostri stati interiori.
Per cui abbiamo cominciato
ad acquisire una sensibilità,
e quindi ci siamo costruiti
degli universi, delle cosmogonie.
Abbiamo cominciato a pensare agli dèi,
abbiamo cominciato
a costruire degli idoli.
degli idoli che ci somigliassero
e fossero le nostre metafore,
degli idoli che parlavano
e quindi davano a noi la possibilità
di vedere rappresentato, allucinato,
quello che noi pensavamo di essere.
Questo fa sempre parte
del nostro cammino evolutivo.
Noi in questo momento, però,
stiamo compiendo
in maniera forse inconsapevole,
in circa una ventina d'anni,
un salto evolutivo
altrettanto potente per noi
come è stato quello
che in 17 milioni di anni
ci ha dato il pollice opponibile.
È quello di avere iniziato
a pensare l'idea
che noi potessimo avere
delle protesi emotive
che in qualche maniera andassero
oltre quelli che erano
i limiti dei nostri sensi.
Ho un po' sorriso quando qualcuno
ha detto, prima che iniziassimo:
"Spegnete i cellulari!"
Come dire: spegnete quello
che noi abbiamo a disposizione oggi
per osservare a tempo reale
la nostra evoluzione.
Noi stiamo cercando alla stessa maniera
in cui abbiamo cominciato
a cambiare il mondo,
a cambiare anche la nostra sensibilità,
a cambiare la nostra percezione
degli altri esseri umani,
della nostra dimensione spazio-temporale,
proprio attraverso questo oggetto
che ognuno di voi ha.
Il fatto che ognuno di voi
ne abbia uno in tasca
significa che ormai
è una protesi irrinunciabile.
È soltanto per un mero arcaismo
che ancora, noi, mese dopo mese
vediamo il nuovo modello di smartphone,
ci fermiamo rispetto a quello
che è l'hardware,
quello che all'esterno di questo oggetto.
In realtà è la sua essenza:
la nostra evoluzione
sarà completa in questa fase
quando noi avremo incorporata
questa possibilità ulteriore
di avere degli spazi più ampi
rispetto a quelli, limitati,
dei nostri sensi.
Come questo cerchio rosso,
come quel countdown che segna
che mancano 9 minuti
e 18 secondi alla fine.
Questo significa che dobbiamo
vedere e osservare,
essere consapevoli
che il mondo che stiamo vivendo
è un mondo che sta registrando
il nostro cambiamento,
perché noi stiamo cambiando.
Come noi siamo cambiati
con il pollice opponibile,
abbiamo cominciato a cambiare
il nostro mondo,
noi stiamo cambiando
con questa nostra percezione
che comunque abbiamo una nuova maniera
per gestire la socialità.
La socialità significa esperienza:
il nostro cervello muta, cambia,
con la relazione con gli altri.
Una volta un'amica mia,
che è una scienziata,
mi ha detto:
"io ti cambio, cambio qualcosa di te".
Mi tocca una mano con le unghie:
“ora le tue sinapsi
sono composte in una certa maniera,
quindi ti ho cambiato il cervello.
Tu hai un cambiamento fisico
soltanto con una carezza;
figuriamoci quanto cambiamo,
e quanto stiamo cambiando,
dallo stress che non eravamo
abituati a gestire,
di avere, non so, 20-30.000
contatti in un social network.
E avere il database organizzato
di tutte le nostre relazioni,
non avere più una gerarchia di relazioni
se non un ordine alfabetico
delle relazioni che noi gestiamo.
Beh, questo è fantastico.
Questo cambierà il mondo.
Questo muterà il mondo.
A tendere, noi riusciremo
a incorporare questa facoltà.
E come questi occhiali -
che in realtà sono una protesi:
senza occhiali comincio a vedere sfocato
dalla prima fila in poi,
quindi ho una protesi per acuire
il mio senso della vista -
non mi basterebbe
la vista
per gestire 900 persone.
Ma quando mai s’è posto, un uomo,
il problema di guardare
in faccia 900 persone?
Non ho possibilità fisiche,
legate ai miei sensi,
di gestire i 50.000 contatti
che magari ho nel mio social network.
Quindi ho bisogno di una protesi.
Alla fine
mi comincia a pesare il fatto
che sia un oggetto che devo tenere
fuori dal mio corpo,
e lo vorrò dentro.
Quella che era la fantastica anticipazione
di alcuni performer di body art,
negli anni ‘70, come Stelarc
che si mangiava
dei piccoli meccanismi dicendo:
il corpo umano è pieno di zone vuote,
bisogna riprogettare il corpo umano.
Ma noi stiamo riprogettando
il corpo umano!
Noi stiamo dando corpo
a una nuova dinastia di esseri umani,
anche cambiando le fattezze fisiche.
Le nostre dimensioni corporee,
la nostra espressione mutava
secondo l’uso che facevamo dell'ambiente:
camminavamo tanto, ci venivano
delle gambe lunghe e affusolate;
stiamo molto seduti, diventiamo sedentari
e ci viene la gastrite.
Ma, artificialmente, abbiamo capito
che può essere cambiato.
Ma figuriamoci, non c'è più il tabù
dell’incorporamento di oggetti estranei,
della tecnologia che entra
nel nostro corpo.
Ma che male c'è?
Mi fa male un ginocchio?
Mi dicono, tra qualche anno
metterai la protesi.
Sì, metterò una cosa al vanadio qua,
e chi se ne importa.
Rischia di scoppiare il cuore?
Mi metteranno un po' di valvole,
siamo abituati.
Ma siamo abituati non soltanto
all'avanguardia nel nostro pensiero:
tutti sono abituati!
Una persona anziana sa
che se ha un problema cardiaco
gli mettono dei bypass, delle valvoline
e continua a vivere.
Quindi è già superato, il tabù:
non esiste più una differenza
tra organico e inorganico,
anzi l’inorganico entra tranquillamente
a far parte del nostro corpo,
della nostra esperienza.
Ci sono anche altre mutazioni, però.
Mutazioni che in realtà
avvengono proprio per usi sociali.
Un'altra importante mutazione
che abbiamo avuto
è la perdita del baculum.
Il baculum è l'osso penico,
che una volta era importante
perché eravamo poligami,
c’erano tante donne e ci serviva
un attrezzo sempre a disposizione.
Poi siamo diventati monogami,
abbiamo cambiato le nostre abitudini
e mi pare che un milione
e mezzo di anni fa
abbiamo perso il baculum.
Lo mantengono alcuni primati,
l'uomo non ce l'ha più.
Quindi, un uso sociale
ha cambiato il nostro corpo.
E perché non dovrebbe
cambiare il nostro corpo
un uso sociale come quello di avere
la nostra possibilità
di relazionarci allargata?
Questo ha sempre appassionato, diciamo,
i miei ultimi anni di attenzione.
Per tanti anni
ho osservato la televisione,
il mio compito era appunto,
come ha detto la persona
che mi ha introdotto,
di fare il massmediologo.
Un termine
che mi è sempre sembrato odioso,
anche perché avevo l'impressione
di osservare una realtà transeunte
che non era possibile codificare
in un sistema scientifico.
La comunicazione...
noi cambiamo continuamente,
non puoi dire cosa sia la comunicazione!
Quando nacquero le prime facoltà
di Scienza della Comunicazione,
ridevo: ma scienza di che?
Questi studiavano televisione,
i soloni spiegavano cos'è la televisione.
La televisione oggi non esiste più:
quando la osservavo io
una decina d'anni fa già dicevo:
sì, è un Medium.
Ma perché è un Medium?
È un Medium nell'accezione
primaria di questo termine:
è un evocatore di realtà fantasmatiche.
La televisione non è importante.
Non ci fa vedere nulla,
non ci ha fatto evolvere,
non è l'oggetto
che cambierà la nostra vita.
Lasciatelo dire quello alle vestali
che ogni giorno si strappano i capelli,
dicono: "Ah, come cambia il mondo,
la cattiva televisione,
la buona televisione..."
Non esiste, roba passata.
È un Medium, è servito
per un certo periodo
a farci vedere
una realtà di oltretomba
in cui tutti ambivano ad entrare.
Era l'addestratore, alla concezione,
alla percezione della protesi emotiva.
La televisione altro
non ha fatto poi, alla fine,
che osservare l'umanità
e non inventarsi più nulla.
La televisione non è più assimilabile
a una realtà come la poesia, la narrativa:
no, per la televisione --
la televisione generalista, parlo:
la televisione dei telefilm
è un'altra cosa,
è una trasposizione del teatro,
è il teatro a casa.
La televisione non ha fatto altro
che osservare la realtà
e cominciare a dimostrare
che le persone che la guardavano
entravano all'interno del suo spettacolo.
Benissimo, tutto questo l'ho fatto
per una parte importante della mia vita
quindi osservavo la comunicazione,
osservavo i mezzi di comunicazione,
dicevo: abbiamo queste protesi emotive
incorporate dentro di noi.
Che bello, comunicheremo tanto.
Voglio studiare, capire, immaginare.
Volevo essere avanti rispetto agli altri,
capire cosa sarebbe successo
il giorno dopo.
Poi improvvisamente nella mia vita
è accaduto che mi è nato
un figlio autistico.
Perlomeno, ho avuto la percezione
di avere un figlio autistico.
Un essere umano che ha
un problema di comunicazione:
la totale incomunicabilità,
o la radicale incomunicabilità.
Che dovevo fare, a quel punto lì?
Avevo due strade: una strada è quella
che la maggior parte,
ahimè, delle famiglie
che hanno un ragazzo autistico
fanno in Italia:
sono tante, perché statisticamente ormai
nasce un autistico ogni 100 bambini,
quindi qualcosa sta cambiando comunque.
Ho cominciato a osservare il mondo
visto da una persona che non comunicava,
e ho capito qualcosa
di fondamentale, in realtà.
Noi ci stiamo evolvendo,
e le persone che non comunicano
non sono altro che l'anticipazione
della nostra fase futura dell'evoluzione.
E stranamente, su queste persone
si è creata una sorta
di guerra di religione:
oggi l'autismo, la neurodiversità,
è al centro di una sorta
di nuovo movimento di rivolta:
cosa fate ai nostri bambini?!
Li vaccinate, li fate
diventare tutti autistici?
Dio mio, che succederà?
Non comunicheranno più!
Ci toglierete questa facoltà fantastica
che tutti noi possiamo
esprimere un'opinione:
abbiamo uno smartphone
e nei social network,
anche se siamo radicalmente
degli analfabeti funzionali,
possiamo dire quello che vogliamo.
Quindi la paura è che quella
che viene considerata la nuova frontiera
del potere ottuso e assoluto
che è la scienza,
questa modesta cosa
che ci ha fatto evolvere,
che fa sì che voi
state qua in buona salute,
che ci siano delle luci,
che io possa parlare,
che lascerò questa fetta della mia vita
dove potrà continuare a parlare
quando non ci sarò più,
è diventato il grande spauracchio.
E l'oggetto dello spauracchio
sono proprio i bambini:
ci fate morire i nostri bambini!
Ma guardate che c'è sempre stata una paura
verso quelli che mangiavano i bambini.
Il primo pregiudizio verso gli Ebrei
era che ammazzassero i bambini
per berne il sangue,
e fare dei loro rituali.
E ho cominciato a studiare
la non comunicazione,
ho cominciato a spiegare a queste persone
che non è che ci sono delle cause esterne,
cattivi che avvelenano i vostri bambini
o avvelenano voi con i vaccini,
o con un'infinità di altre cose.
No: i nostri figli sono così
perché noi siamo così.
Ce l'abbiamo già noi dentro
il nostro patrimonio genetico.
Per fare questo,
dimostrare questo, cosa ho fatto?
Ho passato due mesi della mia vita
a farmi diagnosticare
la percentuale che ho di autismo.
E ho una forte percentuale di autismo,
che riesco a gestire.
Sono autistico, fortemente autistico.
Quindi in me già vedo la possibilità
di questa nuova evoluzione.
Quale sarà la nuova società?
La società degli autistici.
Non saranno persone
che non comunicheranno:
avranno una comunicazione diversa,
più selettiva.
Abbandoneranno alcuni cascami
che in questo momento limitano
la nostra esistenza:
l'emotività, la personalità,
la famiglia, tutte queste cose.
Certo, c'è un lato in questo
abbastanza negativo,
proprio riguardo appunto
alla delimitazione del proprio tempo,
alla sopravvivenza.
La mia vera angoscia è che avrò
un figlio che mi sopravviverà.
E questo sembra paradossale,
ma non ci dormo la notte.
È assolutamente contro natura avere paura
di un figlio che sopravvive.
Perché? Perché avrò un figlio
con un cervello diverso
in una società che dà valore
soltanto al cervello omologato.
E quindi quello che riuscirò a fare,
in questo lasso di tempo,
da quando uscirò da questo cerchio
che delimita il mio spazio,
e quando arriverà a zero il timer
che delimita il mio tempo,
è cercare il più possibile di lanciare
l'orgoglio per i cervelli diversi.
Il mio sarà un coming-out:
io ho un cervello diverso.
Sono matto, e allora? Cos'è?
La nuova società sarà fatta
di matti come me.
Sarà una società diversa,
molto più leggera, meno legata
alle tradizioni, alle convenzioni,
alle paure, alle superstizioni.
Sarà più efficiente.
(Applausi)